wird unser gesundheitssystem überfordert
oder nicht denn der gesundheitsschutz
steht an oberster stelle
aber an den tagen sehen wir ja zum
beispiel und das sagen uns die leute die
sich auf den produktionsfaktor verlassen
genauso oder auf die neue fall die neue
fallzahl da sehen wir dass wir einen
schritt vorangekommen sind aber ist es
immer noch nicht so dass man sagen
könnte wir können jetzt in irgendeiner
weise entwarnung geben sondern es ist
nicht der tag an dem wir bereits
aussagen treffen können das sagt uns
auch kein virologen das heißt wir haben
jetzt erstmal bis zum einschließlich 19
april unsere maßnahmen getroffen daran
wird sich auch nichts ändern
ich will hier an dieser stelle sagen
dass aus meiner sicht europa die
europäische union vor der größten
bewährungsprobe seit ihrer gründung
steht das unbenommen wir haben eine
große herausforderung für die gesundheit
unserer bevölkerung alle mitgliedstaaten
der europäischen union wenn auch in
abgestufter weise so sind alle betroffen
ist ist eine ein symmetrischer schock
wie man das etwas technisch bezeichnet
das heißt alle sind davon gleichermaßen
betroffenen heime zu der tatsache dass
wir auch nationale beziehungsweise mit
europa abgestimmte wege gehen wollen
wenn es um schutzausrüstungen
persönliche schutzausrüstung geht hier
insbesondere auch die produktion von
masken
ich glaube bei aller tatsache dass
dieser markt jetzt im augenblick in
asien angesiedelt ist ist es doch auch
wichtig dass wir als eine erfahrung aus
dieser pandemie lernen dass wir hier
auch eine gewisse souveränität brauchen
oder zumindest eine säule der
eigenfertigung das kann in deutschland
sein wir werden es aber auch europaweit
versuchen abzustimmen